PROFESSOR: Build
things, what we'll do
is this stuff will
go on the web.
Usually, we put it
up the night before.
We had some problems
with Stellar,
but normally, you can actually
see the lecture notes the night
before on the web as a PDF.
And there will always be a
paper copy for you here as well.
Let me go through a
few practical things.
So you know who we are.
We have no TA this year.
Normally, we have a TA.
Because it's an off
year, we're actually
going to run this with
students out of our own group.
Because there are five lab
sessions, and there you
will have students from
our own group helping you.
We will meet here for
the lectures, 1390,
but the labs will be in 1115.
There'll be five of them, and
we'll announce them well ahead
of time.
There is a course website
which is on Stellar.
There's not much on
there, like I said,
because we had some
problems with it.
But for later in the
day and tomorrow,
you'll see course materials
being uploaded on there.
This is where extra
readings, for example,
will be uploaded or
links to readings,
in case we can't
post them ourselves.
Grades are determined
by five problem sets.
So there are five lab sessions.
The way they work is that
instead of coming to class,
we meet in the lab.
And we give you an assignment,
modeling assignment,
and you start it there.
And then you will never
be able to finish it
in that 90 minutes, but
then you take it home.
And typically, you have two to
three weeks for it to be due.
So think of it as an
extended homework problem.
We start you in
the lab, because we
feel it's important we solve
the practical problems.
You have to get a cold
running or something
to do the modeling.
So once that's done, you can
just take it home and finish it
there.
And we will give
you computer access,
so you don't need
your own computing
resources of where to run that.
So we'll work that all
out in the first lab.
And so because of that, there's
no final exam in this course.
I wouldn't really
know what to ask.
There's one thing.
We really like
students, if you're
a graduate student, to
register for credit,
so not just listener status.
This is a course that's not
required in any program.
So the only way these
courses stay alive
is if people actually
register for them.
It's a sad thing, but the
university administration only
counts registered
students in a class.
So if we don't do this, we
have 20 people sitting here,
but on paper, my dean tells me I
only had three people in class,
and that's how it's
counted in the department.
So we really want
people to register.
Also, that forces you
to do the problems,
and I feel in a modeling course,
there really isn't much use
if you don't do the problems.
Postdocs, of course,
can't really register,
so those are free to
just come and listen.
But I hope if your
postdoc or anything else,
visitor, that you also come
to the labs to do those.
I think we have about 20 seats,
so we'll be fine with that.
OK.
We don't have a very
specific course text,
but like I said, in some case,
we'll give you review articles.
We'll give you handouts.
There's a few good books
though that you may want
to browse through on occasion.
So depending on what's
your main interest,
the book by Allen and
Tildesley is an old classic
on computer
simulation of liquids.
In the end, it's really a
book on molecular dynamics.
It's quite old by now,
but it's a very good basis
to start from.
It doesn't have the
most advanced algorithms
or new techniques in it
per se, but it's really
still a very good book.
Rob Phillips wrote a newer
book on, essentially,
modeling which both
contains continuum
and atomistic modeling.
That has a heavy slant
on mechanical behavior.
So if you're more
interested in that,
that may be a book that
you want to look into.
Jensen is one of my favorites,
although it's heavily
chemistry focused, modeling
of molecules and so,
but it's actually
very clearly written.
And Thijssen is a
great book if you
want to focus on ab
initio methods and quantum
mechanics, which we'll
do later in the course.
And Frenkel and
Smit is my favorite
for statistical
mechanics, if you
want to learn about the
statistical mechanics
of molecular dynamics
and Monte Carlo
methods and things like that.
This is really a very, very
good book, very thoroughly done.
OK.
So I should say a few words
about the course objectives.
When we designed this
course, we deliberately
made it a somewhat introductory
and overview subject.
We wanted this to be a course
that was not for experts.
So if you already know
everything about ab initio
methods and molecular
dynamics and Monte Carlo,
you may actually start
getting bored after a while.
We really wanted this to be a
course that an average graduate
student, somebody who was
doing experimental research
for example, also could take.
So what we mainly
try to do is teach
the tools of modern
computation materials science
and how they can be applied
to diverse materials problems.
So we will give you technical
details of the tools
but only to the extent that
you need them to understand
how you can apply them.
OK?
So we will, of course,
tell you, for example
what molecular dynamics is,
what the basis is of it,
what some of the
basic algorithms are.
But we will not go into the
very detailed, novel algorithms
to make it a factor of too
fast or something like that.
So we will not do a lot of
detailed algorithmic work
in the course.
So there is a heavy focusing on
understanding the physics that
goes in and because of that the
physics and the applications
that can come out.
So because of that,
you will occasionally
see us teach materials theory
rather than computation.
Because in some cases, I feel
the hard part of computation
is knowing what to
compute, and for that,
you need some basic
materials here.
Like when I do a case study
on diffusion, towards the end,
I may have to tell you a little
bit about diffusion theory,
activation barriers and
correlation factors,
because then we can actually
connect that to the things
we can calculate.
So you should think of this
as a course in modeling
towards material science
and materials application.
We do very little purely
numerical work, actually almost
none to speak of.
OK.
So the way I see atomistic
modeling is really
as the integration of
these four basic fields--
physics, mathematics, computer
science, and material science,
and that's how we'll
tend to approach it.
Let me go through the
calendar, because it gives you
a broad outline of the course.
This calendar is always
subject to change.
Even though we teach
this with two people,
we never seem to able to get our
travel schedules coordinated.
In some cases, we
also slip a little,
but the gross outline
will remain the same.
Essentially, there's
the first section,
which I would say is energy
descriptions which is
essentially from here to here.
This is energy methods.
And it starts with
more empirical methods,
potentials things like
embedded atom method,
and then it goes into ab initio.
So this is largely DFT, although
we do some quantum chemistry.
We give it some quantum
chemistry basis as well.
After that, it's really
finite temperature techniques.
So we do Molecular
Dynamics, MD, and that
runs into coarse-graining
theory and Monte Carlo.
So this is really
finite temperature.
OK, and after that,
it really is a--
I'll be honest-- a
set of random topics.
We do case studies.
Last year, I did
one on hyperdynamics
which is accelerated
molecular dynamics.
We did one on diffusion.
This year, we have
great ambitions
to do one on
Green-Kubo relations
and how you can extract
transport properties.
We have a great lecture
from Chris Wolverton,
which we've done every year,
which students really like.
Chris is the Head of Scientific
Computing in Ford Motor Company
and gives a lecture on how
they use even first principles
calculation and modeling
in general, in Ford
and has a brilliant case that.
It's really fascinating
lecture, how they
saved the company millions.
It's a great story how they
saved the company millions
by doing quantum mechanics.
So stay tuned for that.
So that's roughly how we work.
As you can see, there
are labs interspersed--
three, four, where
is number three?
Here we go.
Essentially, one on generic
modeling which is really
getting you introduced
to building cells,
and we do this with
potential models.
Two on density
functional theory,
one on the molecular
dynamics, and one
on Monte Carlo and
coarse-graining methods.
So that's roughly how
the course will work.
So there are any questions
on the schedule or topic
coverage in the course?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How long are the labs,
and when do they take place?
PROFESSOR: Well the
labs, so they start--
they are essentially
during lecture time,
but then you will have
to continue it on own.
So we get you started
on the problem,
introduce you, show you where
the codes are, how to run them.
And typically, in
the earlier labs
that are not computationally
intensive, like the first one,
you can really run
things and the answer
comes back in no time.
So we actually get some
results already in class
and discuss them.
On some of the computationally
more intensive ones,
like DFT, there'll would be
less of that and more time
that you need to spend
afterwards with them.
OK?
They tend to have
about a due date that's
two to three weeks
after the actual lab.
OK?
Any other questions?
OK.
So I wanted to talk a
little about the growing
importance of modeling.
I started computational
modeling in 1988,
when it was a rarity, especially
in material science department.
Now, you see it everywhere.
It's one of these
enormously growing fields.
You'd be surprised, but even
atomistic level modeling is
probably now more
intensively done in industry
than it is in academia.
We think of it as a
broader academic subject,
but it really has taken a
foothold in corporations.
I wanted to show you
a few examples of how
I think that really showed
the impact of modeling,
where modeling is used to
make important decisions.
This is a picture
from the ASCI Program.
When the US was planning to sign
the Nuclear Stockpile Treaty,
which meant that--
the nuclear stockpile treaty is
basically that you cannot test
nuclear missiles anymore
by setting them off.
Because essentially that's
so the US was concerned
how could we verify
the reliability
of nuclear missiles,
because they're essentially
going to sit for 100
years in their silo.
And there was an enormous
program in the US
for, literally, they would just
blow one up once in a while
to see if it still
works, and now, they
can't do that anymore.
Although, the US has
actually not ratified
the Nuclear Stockpile
Treaty, they still
are sticking with it.
And some, I don't
know, smart people
decided what are we going to
do with all this money which
was several hundred
million dollars.
So they decided,
well, we're going
to model the reliability
of nuclear missiles,
and that led to what's called
ASCI Program, the Advanced
Simulation Computing
Initiative, which is literally
one of the largest computational
modeling programs in the world
now.
It's definitely
not all atomistics,
but there definitely is a large
atomistic component on it.
And the whole idea was,
as they call it cynically,
it's modeling from
button to boom.
So they model everything--
aging of plutonium,
aging of corrosion of
the alloys, corrosion
of the electronics.
Whether actually the time
is actually ripe for that
is another question.
Whether you can reliably
model all these things
is another question.
But just another
example that computing
has taken on a quite
important role.
Here's my favorite.
This is-- or was, I
don't know if was--
this was the largest computer
for a while, the Earth
Simulator, in Japan.
When it came out, it was
the largest computer.
I think it eclipsed the
fastest computer in the US
by a factor of five,
when it came out,
and it's solely used to model
environmental processes.
The whole idea was that the
Japanese had the ambitious idea
that they really wanted to use
this for predicting climate
change in the end.
There's other work done,
but that's its main purpose.
I think now Blue Light
that's being built,
but that is actually
not quite active,
in Livermore, will
be bigger than this.
But again, you see enormous
computational resources spent.
This is I think like several
hundred million dollar setup,
enormous computational
resources being set up
to deal with what's in the end
the very important problem,
environmental change.
OK.
People usually don't believe
me, but I once in my head
made up a list of
companies where
I knew they were
doing first principles
modeling in companies, and
this is not a complete study.
This is just the ones that
I visited, that I know of.
There's actually not
a complete study out,
and I'll put the link on
the web, this study that
was sponsored by the
National Science Foundation
and the University of Loyola.
Where literally a
panel for two years
visited companies all around
the world and looked at what
they did with modeling.
And so there's an enormously
comprehensive list
there of the kind
of work that's being
done in companies with
computational modeling
on materials.
But again, so you see a lot of
big companies in here actually.
The largest groups
that I know of
are probably at Motorola,
Siemens, Ford, Nippon Steel,
and I think these days
at Toyota as well.
These all have very substantial
groups in atomistic modeling
on materials.
OK.
So this course is supposed
to be interactive.
We used to have this
course in a small room.
This is a bit of an
unusually big setting for us.
So normally, like there's not
enough seats for people which
makes us feel much better.
So this is supposed to
be somewhat interactive.
So like MBA classes do,
they ask you questions,
and you're supposed to answer.
Why are you here in the end?
Why do you think
modeling is useful?
I know there's
some familiar faces
here, people who did
for the research,
but what do you think--
what's so useful about it?
Why do you think
companies do it?
Because anything companies do
is because it makes them money,
or it saves them money.
So what's so great about it?
Too early in the
morning for that.
Huh?
What can you do
better or faster,
or what is it that
you cannot, maybe,
unless you do it with modeling?
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: You can
set exact variables.
Like in your
experiment, you might
think, if you're trying
to set variables,
that they're changing
a little bit.
PROFESSOR: You hit
the nail right on.
That's actually number one.
It's not the one you
usually bring up, control.
The number one reason people
use modeling is control.
In essence, think of
it as doing experiments
in a controlled environment.
OK?
So because you have
anomalous control,
you can very quickly understand
what goes on in your systems,
assuming that the answer
that comes out is right.
That is the number one reason,
to solve, to isolate phenomena
by controlling the variables.
But what else do you think?
There's usually one that people
always bring up right away.
AUDIENCE: To do the experiment.
PROFESSOR: You don't have
to do the experiment.
So to predict things
without having
to do the work of
the experiment,
and that's definitely
becoming more and more
an important role.
OK?
It's still done
less than you think.
Most modeling is still
done on materials
that have already been made
and that people have already
done the experiment on and that
they're trying to understand.
But more and more
what you bring up
which is trying to predict
truly before you actually
do the experiment, the virtual
searching for materials
is playing a more and
more important role.
Let me show you a few
examples that point this out.
There's another one
that we didn't bring up,
and it's using modeling where
you cannot do the experiment
or where it's really very
hard or very expensive to do
the experiment.
And here's one, this
is from Alfie's group,
which is, I think,
Cambridge or--
AUDIENCE: London.
PROFESSOR: London, close by.
OK.
Where knowing what
the composition is
of the mantle in the Earth, both
the composition and the phases
that are present, is an
enormously difficult problem.
But it's one of these
actually quite literally
hot problems in
materials geology.
We know that there's iron
and magnesium and oxygen
and silicon and a few other
things, but in the end,
we really don't know
what phases they
form, what their
elastic properties are,
and things like that.
And the experiments
are really hard.
Somewhere in the
mantle, pressures
are I think anywhere from
50 to maybe 300 gigapascals.
These are really hard
experiments to do.
And I was yesterday at
the University of Illinois
in the Department of
Geology, and they showed me
the way they do high pressure
experiments with diamond anvil
cells.
You need about a 1/4 to 1/2 a
carat diamond, first of all,
so these people have a safe in
their lab, it's pretty cool,
where they're diamonds sit.
And then you have to make
really small samples,
pushed very hard on them
with a diamond anvil.
OK?
So you're really pushing on it.
This sits in an
enormous container,
because you have
to keep a hundred
gigapascal on this
thing, and then you
have to characterize it.
Can you imagine?
So you have this
enormous holder,
because you're putting
it under 100 GPa,
and you've got to see inside.
So they're really hard
experiments to do.
You can't really control
the temperature very well.
So this is where
modeling is great,
if you believe the answers.
So a lot of people do
computational quantum mechanics
on phases under high pressure.
High pressure is
trivial in computation.
Just push on it, you change
the lattice parameter,
and you constrain it.
You control the variable,
and you have high pressure.
300 gigapascal, no problem.
OK.
This one I particularly like.
There was an article
in the New York Times.
This is when science made the
New York Times which doesn't
happen too often, in 1999.
The people had basically
been able to visualize
electron densities, orbitals,
and that's the left picture.
This is I think in copper oxide.
I forgot what this is.
In some copper oxide,
where they literally
were able to visualize
the orbitals,
and they look like d
orbitals, don't they?
This is actually one
of these things that
is quite an experimental feat.
It made the New York
Times, because people
could do it experimentally.
This is trivial computationally.
When you do computational
quantum mechanics,
you will get orbitals
and orbital populations.
That doesn't mean that
the experiment is useless.
OK?
Because the experiment could
be the critical verification
of what you do in your theory,
but I'm just showing you
that these things have an
enormously different level
of complexity.
And if you're ever going
to use both computations
and experiment, the one key
thing that will put you ahead
is understanding what is
most efficient for a given
problem, either
computation or experiment.
Because the complexity of either
has no relation to each other.
So for some
problems, computation
is extremely efficient, and
experiment is really hard,
and for some problems,
it's the other way around.
And understanding
where to use what,
if you're going to
use both, I think
is the thing that would
really get you ahead.
And unfortunately,
most of the time,
that doesn't happen,
because usually people only
do one of the two.
Here, for example,
this is actually
from Professor Marzari,
the electron density
in lead titanate which is a
perovskite, a ferroelectric.
So you see beautiful orbitals
without the graininess
of experiments.
The other thing
is, sometimes, you
can do things fast
computationally.
This is out of my own work.
One of the areas we work in is
predicting crystal structure.
Typically, getting a phase
diagram of a material
used to take about a PhD thesis.
It takes you that long
to make all the samples,
do the structural analysis,
get the phase boundaries.
In about a six month time frame,
we ran 15,000-- it says 10,000.
We were up at 15,000--
first principles calculations
to find the structures,
the ground-state structures
in 80 metallic systems, 80
binary metallic systems.
So in some sense, we did 80 PhD
thesises in about six months.
So there are certain
things that you can now
solve more efficiently
computationally
than experimentally.
And I think it makes
sense, like let's say
you are looking for
structure of material,
to first do the
computation, and then
when you need to resolve
issues, then do the experiment,
rather than first blindly
do the experiment.
And we'll talk a little more
later about these things.
Control, we already
talked about control.
That's the number one.
Here's one of the first examples
of where I saw that applied.
In the early '80s,
aluminum lithium
was one of the key
alloys that people
thought of for airframes.
Because of course now,
airframes are aluminum copper.
If you want to make
it lighter, you
have to go to lighter elements.
Well, lithium is the
lightest solid element.
So substituting the copper
away and using aluminum lithium
alloys was supposed to
make really light alloys.
It didn't pan out, because
they're not very weldable.
So you actually find very little
aluminum lithium on airplanes
these days.
But the key issue in
aluminum lithium is that--
this is the stable
phase diagram.
So there's an FCC solid solution
in equilibrium with a compound,
but what actually
strengthens the material is
a metastable precipitate
which is in here.
And because it's metastable,
it's very hard to study,
because to study it,
you need to make it big.
To strengthen the alloys,
you have to keep it small.
But to study it,
like with microscopy,
you need to make it big enough.
But the problem is you can't
anneal the precipitate,
because it's metastable.
If you anneal it to
long, it goes away.
OK.
So this was a great
one for computation.
In computation, something
that's metastable,
you can easily make it stable
by not letting the system evolve
to whatever is stable, and
that's what was done here.
This is a calculated
phase diagram
completely from first principles
with the stable equilibria
in solid lines and then
the metastable equilibrium,
this was the precipitant phase.
And so you can just
isolate this thing
and look at it separately.
OK.
Let me skip that one.
You can use computation
often to prove or disprove
hypotheses in cases where it's
hard to see experimentally.
A really ongoing and long story
has been the defect in silicon.
How do vacancies
or interstitials
look like in silicon?
The reason that
they're a little odd
is because it's such
an open structure.
Whereas in a close-packed
metal, a vacancy
is just taking an atom
out, and interstitials,
you're just taking putting one
in the interstitial position.
But because in silicon it's such
a close-packed and covalently
bonded network, every
time you take an atom out,
you can actually have quite
a bit of rearrangement
of the other atoms.
So it's quite an old
problem, and it's probably
a problem where computation
has made considerable impact.
If you have an idea for how the
vacancy or interstitials should
look like, you can test
it computationally.
You can calculate its
energy and compare it
to other potential arrangements.
OK.
This is my last
piece of philosophy.
After that, we'll
start doing real work.
But this is one that if you
didn't remember anything
from the class except
one thing, this is
the one I want you to remember.
If you do modeling, and
people will come up to you,
and they will call
it simulation,
and modeling is not
the same as simulation.
You should keep that in mind.
We actually do computation.
Maybe we do modeling.
We rarely ever do simulation.
We sometimes do simulation.
The reason is that
reality is very often
too complex to simulate.
OK?
So rather, what we do is we
isolate parts of reality.
OK?
We say, this subset
is important,
and we do computation on that.
And what that means is
that you will very often
have to make judgments.
OK?
Like if you're going
to study corrosion,
let's say you're going to study
corrosion of a high strength
steel.
There is no way in hell
you're going to simulate that,
because you don't even know
what the relevant variables are.
You don't even know what the
relevant environments are.
OK?
So what you're
going to have to do
is learn a lot about
the signs of corrosion,
and take one isolated
element, maybe
surface attack by
chlorine or something
like that or hydrogen going
in and locally embrittling
the material.
So you will never just take
your high strength steel,
put it in a computer,
and wait for a long time,
because you don't even know
what environment to impose
on that system.
OK?
So rarely do we do simulation
to solve complex problems.
Sometimes, we will
isolate a piece
and then simulate on
that, but we rarely
simulate the full reality.
And because of that,
it's really important
that you know the signs
of the field you work in.
OK?
You cannot have impact
with computation without
understanding your field
of application, period,
because you will never
know what to compute.
OK?
So I think if you
want to remember
one thing, that's the one.
The hardest part of computing
is knowing what to compute.
OK?
Everybody can learn
molecular dynamics.
ab initio methods,
but using them in an intelligent
way becomes the hard part.
And I like the quote
from Frank Jensen,
computers don't solve
problems, people
do, to paraphrase something.
OK.
I'm going to skip this.
I'll let you read this, an
article we put on the web
from James Langer.
People are trying to
establish computing
as the third branch of science.
There's experiment, there's
theory, and there's computing,
and it's an interesting article.
OK.
So let me get to
the real science
that we can do today,
at least a little bit.
So the first maybe
a few weeks or so,
we're going to talk
about energy models.
And the reason we start with
energy models is because I feel
that, unless you have an
adequate energetic description
of your material, you really
don't know if what comes out
of your computations is
actually right or relevant.
So typically, people distinguish
empirical energy models
from ab initio or
quantum mechanical,
so this is what
we sometimes call
ab initio, or first principles.
In some sense, in empirical
models, all you do
is you take some
form for the energy,
and you fit it to any
data you may have,
and sometimes, that data is
quantum mechanically computed.
In quantum mechanics, you
leave the fitting aside,
and you go straight
to just solving
the Schrodinger equation
for whatever problem
you're trying to solve.
And there are methods
in between which
are semi-empirical which
are essentially quantum
mechanical in form but
empirical in the parameters.
Essentially tied binding
fits into these, things
that the chemists often
do, like MINDO and INDO.
So these are effectively,
you could think of them
as parameterized Schrodinger
equations almost,
where the overlap integrals
between wave functions
are not computed but
are parameterized.
So you save a lot of time.
Personally, I believe that
that middlefield is losing
in importance considerably.
I think if we'd given
this class 10 years ago,
we would have talked
a lot about that.
Because people see
that as a way of like,
well, it's much
faster than ab initio,
but you keep some of
the accuracy of it.
I think that's less and
less true these days.
You don't keep as much accuracy
as you usually want to,
and it's not as
much faster anymore.
So while there are
obviously still problems
where this is important,
more and more people
just do the ab initio, period.
Computers are cheap these days.
The reason we teach you
about empirical models
is because, first of
all, you will encounter,
and if you're going to do
really, really large problems,
they can be quite useful.
And also, they are really great
handle I find to teach you some
of the essential energy physics
that you need to deal with when
studying different materials,
and so that's why I spend 2,
2 1/2 lectures on
empirical models.
OK.
And so obviously, keep
the obviously in mind,
that if you work
with potentials,
you have no information
about electrons.
You just have energies as
a function of position.
If you work with semi-empirical
and quantum mechanics,
you also have more information.
You know something about
the electronic structure
of the material.
Which one is best, I think
that's an irrelevant question,
depends what you can afford.
OK.
So essentially,
what you want if you
want to do an empirical
modeling method
is that you want to have the
energy as a function of all
the nuclear coordinates.
That already itself
implies an assumption,
because the energy is actually
a function of the nuclear
and the electronic coordinates.
Typically, what we do
is we variationally
remove the electronic
coordinates,
and that's essentially
what's called
the Born-Oppenheimer
approximation.
If you think if
your atom-- if you
have a bunch of atoms together.
So you have a set of coordinates
that describe the positions.
People think that the energy
is uniquely determined
by that set of coordinates,
but that's actually not true.
Because you have electronic
states, and in many cases,
for a given state
of the nuclei, you
can have multiple
electronic states.
OK?
There'll be a ground state, but
you can be in excited states
as well.
What the Born-Oppenheimer
approximation essentially
assumes is that, for any
set of nuclear coordinates,
you are always in the
electronic ground state.
So ER is derived from
ER psi by essentially
variationally removing psi
by minimizing over psi.
OK?
So what's the physical
implementation here?
If you're in a
stationary configuration,
and you wait long enough,
this is probably OK.
If your atoms sit there
frozen in some position,
if you wait long
enough, the electrons
will go to the ground state,
especially when you're
at 0 temperature.
Where is can wreak havoc is
in certain molds of dynamics,
because what you're
really assuming
is that, if you move your
atoms, your electrons follow
infinitely fast.
OK?
Because if you move
the atom a little bit,
the energy change
is the energy change
when the electrons relax
immediately to the ground
state, as you move the atoms.
OK?
That's essentially the
Born-Oppenheimer approximation.
So when is this not
going to be true?
It's when the atoms
move really fast,
or the electrons
move really slow,
and there are cases like that.
This is one of
these approximations
that we want to believe is
always true, because it's
very hard to do anything else.
So we kind of kid
ourselves, because it's
very hard to verify as well.
But there are long-lived
excited states in materials.
There are defects in
semiconductors, for example,
EL2 in gallium arsenide
was a famous one
that has very long-lived
excited states, where
there are essentially two
Born-Oppenheimer surfaces.
Let's call one the
ground state one,
and then there's another one
that's the excited state one.
And the interesting
thing was they gave you
different nuclear coordinates.
So if you minimized it under
one equipotential surface
and under the other
one, you ended up
in a different
nuclear configuration.
So you see then,
you have a problem.
You can find the lowest energy
configuration of the nuclei,
unless you know what
the electrons do.
So you now have a
coupled problem.
OK?
So that's a
non-obvious violation
of the Born-Oppenheimer
approximation.
In fast dynamics, things
that move fast, like protons.
The lightest nucleus or
protons can move very fast,
and in some cases, the electrons
won't follow fast enough.
In insulators, let's say
you studied diffusion
of charged ions in insulators.
OK?
So I work on battery materials.
It's all about lithium
plus diffusion,
lithium ions diffuse.
Well, if the ion diffuses--
if the iron hops very fast,
but I'm in an insulator,
maybe the electron
won't follow fast enough.
OK?
So I'm going away from the
Born-Oppenheimer surface there.
OK?
So this problem actually
appears more than you think.
It's just that we don't
know how to deal with it.
So we like, shush, remove
it from our thoughts.
The other obvious violation
of Born-Oppenheimer
is when you're at
nonzero temperature.
When you're at
nonzero temperature,
you have a finite probability
to actually occupy
the higher level electronic
citations, so the higher energy
electronics states.
That's not a really big problem.
It is technically a violation
of the Born-Oppenheimer
approximation, but essentially,
it's easy to solve.
You can replace this minimum.
So minimizing it
by statistically
averaging over the right
levels by literally
doing a statistical weighting
of how the levels are populated.
Then, they do a statistical
mechanics approach,
and we'll talk much
more about these things
when we talk about
coarse graining
methods in the later
part of the course.
So temperature isn't a big
deal for Born-Oppenheimer.
OK.
So here's what we're
going to do on potentials.
There are as many different
potentials as there are people.
Everybody has
their favorite one.
So we're going to
pick and choose,
and I'm mainly going
to pick and choose
based on the materials physics
I can teach you with them.
So we're going to talk
about a few particular forms
and the physical limitations
that they introduce,
and I'm going to start
with pair potentials,
because they're the obvious one.
That'll be today, and then
that'll obviously lead us,
the failures of those will lead
us into many body potentials
and pair functionals.
This one will be
particularly relevant
for covalent delocalized
materials, like metals,
and this is for delocalized--
sorry.
Sorry, covalent localized.
So we're mainly going to talk
about the form of these things.
I'm not going to
spend a whole lot
of time talking about the
detailed parameters you put in.
OK.
So here's pair potentials.
Obviously, what are
you really saying
when you use pair potentials
to model something?
You're saying that, if I have
a bunch of atoms together,
I can sum their energy
from pairwise interactions.
So you're saying that this
interaction between these two
atoms has nothing to do with
whether this atom or that atom
is present.
That's essentially the
physics of what you're saying.
You're summing the energy.
In some cases, you take a
constant, and then simply
a sum of interaction
potentials that only
depend on the distance
between two atoms.
Pair potentials pretty much
always have the same form.
They are attractive at
intermediate to long distance,
and they are repulsive
at short distance.
And they have to be
repulsive at short distance,
because otherwise, your
system collapses into itself.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
I left my phone.
I just don't see it.
Sorry to interrupt.
PROFESSOR: You left what?
AUDIENCE: My phone.
I'm sorry.
PROFESSOR: I didn't see a phone.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
Sorry.
PROFESSOR: No problem.
OK.
Every lecture will have
something like that.
Something odd happens.
We do it deliberately.
No.
One issue, practical
issue with potentials,
is that you have
to truncate them.
OK?
Because you want to
keep this pairwise
distance not out to infinity.
Most potential is just
the form they have.
They slowly decay, and people
do all kinds of tricks.
The problem is if
you say, I'm only
going to truncate
up to here, that you
have this discontinuity.
Let me see if I can
make a wide slide,
if I remember how to do this.
Ah, magic.
OK.
So let's say I truncate
the potential here
at this distance.
Then essentially, my potential
really looks like this.
I have this discontinuity in
it which is not very good.
Because whenever atoms move
in and out of this range,
they actually have a
strong energy jump,
as they move in and
out of that range.
So people do all
kinds of tricks.
You can smooth this, like
attach some spline to it that
smooths this out to zero.
Sometimes, you want
to have literally zero
at some distance.
Sometimes, you also
like zero derivative,
so you have continuous forces.
Some people use
shifted potentials
which is kind of cute.
If you know that this has some
value, let's say epsilon here,
you just shift the
potential up by epsilon.
So now, it's zero
at your cutoff,
but of course, the
force would still
be discontinuous, because the
force would be the derivative.
OK.
The most simple potential form
that you'll sometimes see used
is the Lennard-Jones
potential which
has an R to the 6th which
is the attractive part.
OK?
That gives you the
attractions and has
the negative sign in front,
and the R to the 12th
which gives you the repulsion.
The R to the 6th
term can actually
be physically justified.
It comes from the interaction
between fluctuating dipoles.
If you have an atom here with
its electron cloud and an atom
here, and if these
are inert atoms,
so with filled electron shell,
so there's no covalent bonding
going on with them.
So these are either ions
with a filled shell,
or they're noble gases.
Then, there is no direct
covalent interaction,
so the interaction you get
is from fluctuating dipoles.
So at some point,
there's a dipole
that, just from fluctuations,
that sets up here,
and that will induce a dipole
in the other electron cloud.
And so the interaction
between these dipoles
and these dipoles, if
you actually look at it,
gives you an R to the 6th.
So this piece is
physically justifiable,
and that's where
Lennard-Jones got it from.
It's essentially
the form of what's
called a Van der Waals
interaction which
is the interaction
between inner shells.
So where does the R to the
12th come from, you think?
Obviously, you need
something steep to get that.
Otherwise, the ions
fly into each other.
You need this steep
repulsive part
when the ions come
very close together,
and essentially what the physics
of it is the Pauli repulsion.
As the electron clouds come
into each other, remember,
the electrons cannot occupy
exactly the same quantum state.
And so as you bring
them closer, you're
almost forcing them to occupy
the same quantum state,
but why R to the 12th?
It's really because it's
the square of R to the 6th.
There is no physical
justification
for R to the 12th.
Lennard-Jones used
it, because it
makes the math of some things
you want to do with it easy,
because it's the
square of R to the 6th.
So if you like R or the 10th,
R to the 14th, R to the 16th,
go ahead.
People always take the
Lennard-Jones potential,
because it's there.
And like I said, the R to
the 6th, I grant you that.
Maybe you should keep that.
That is a true Van
der Waals interaction,
but the R to the 12th,
there is no reason
that it should be R to the 12th.
OK?
Anything, sometimes you actually
want steeper potentials,
so you make it like R to the
20 or something or whatever.
OK.
The other thing is that
people use the Lennard-Jones
potentials to attract
atoms together
that has nothing to do with
Van der Waals interaction,
to actually look at
things that almost
have some covalent interaction.
And then there's
actually no reason
to keep the R of the 6th.
OK?
Because the R to
the 6th is really
only physically justifiable
for Van der Waals terms.
OK.
The interesting thing
about Lennard-Jones,
it's actually the
simplest potential,
because it only
has two parameters.
There's essentially A and
B, or if you renormalize
the potential, there's
an energy scale,
and there's a length scale.
So you see, if you
write it in this form,
you see that the
potential is in units
of epsilon, and the
length, or the sigma which
is the distance--
I'm sorry, the R which is the
distance is in units of sigma.
OK?
So what that means is
that there's essentially
only one Lennard-Jones
system in the world.
You will see tabulated
Lennard-Jones parameters
for a lot of materials,
but if you think of it,
the energy scale
of your potential
sets the temperature
scale of the system.
And the length scale sets
the volume or therefore
the pressure scale.
So if you take one
Lennard-Jones system
at a given temperature
and pressure,
that will always be the
same as a Lennard-Jones
system without the parameters
but at another temperature
and pressure.
So there's a unique
transformation
going between all
Lennard-Jones systems.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: No.
Sometimes, people leave
out that factor of 2.
I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I'm not sure.
I think the reason
the factor 2 is there,
if you differentiate
it, and that way you
find the minimum is
exactly at sigma.
OK?
Because if you differentiate
the 12, you get a factor of 12.
If you differentiate
the 6, you get a 6.
You could leave 2 out, but
then sigma is not the value
where the potential is minimum.
That's the reason people put
sigma there, because I think--
I may be wrong-- but I think
in this form, this is sigma.
OK?
And I actually think
that this is epsilon,
but I should verify that.
So there is essentially
only one Lennard-Jones.
Ah, there's Lennard-Jones.
I forgot his picture.
I think it's sir now, Sir
Lennard-Jones, I think.
OK.
Usually, two parameters is
just not enough in a potential,
and the reason is
that usually you
want to mimic at least three
properties of a material.
Its length scale which is its
largest parameter, its energy
scale which you can think of
as its cohesive energy which
is the potential
depth, but you also
want to get its
elasticity right.
OK?
And so that's three
fundamental properties
to get right, because
its elasticity tells you
its response to
any perturbations.
And the problem is that a
Lennard-Jones potential only
has two parameters.
You cannot fit three
things with two parameters.
So most people will go to
things with three parameters,
usually, so they can get
these three things right.
And one classic is
a Morse potential
which has D which
sets the energy scale,
R0 which sets the length
scale, and alpha which
sets the elasticity scale.
Because you can see
alpha sets in some sense
the curvature of the potential.
It's what you multiply with
the distance differential.
OK?
So alpha will be a measure
of the elastic behavior.
In particular, in oxides,
the form that's most popular
is what's called a Born-Mayor
or a Buckingham potential which
is essentially a decaying
exponential, a Van der Waals
term, and then the second
order term in Van der Waals
perturbation theory which is
the R of the 8th parameter.
The weird thing
about this potential
that you have to be
somewhat careful about
is that it diverges at short
distances if you plot it.
If you plot the
exponential, that
goes to a finite value
of A when R is 0.
So the exponential to
something like this,
and this is A-- it's actually
a lot steeper in reality.
Typically, A is very large, but
these terms, these R to the 6th
and the R to the 8th--
1 over R to the 6th and 1 over
R to the 8th diverge and R
goes to 0.
So they, on the other
hand, look like this, where
this goes to minus infinity.
So when you add the two up,
you get something like this.
I'm sorry.
This is supposed to go down.
So if you look only up to here,
this potential looks fine.
But if you go past it, if you
in some sense go into the core,
the potential diverges, and
you may think that's silly.
You never go there,
but you sometimes
do because of numerical issues.
Sometimes, what happens
in say a simulation is
that, when you start--
let's say you do something
molecular dynamics which
is essentially evolving atoms
according to their force.
You may start in a configuration
very far from equilibrium.
So in the initial steps, atoms
move with tremendous force,
and so because of that, they
can literally just overshoot
and shoot into each other.
And what you see
is that actually
the state with two atoms
on top of each other
is a highly bonded state
in this kind of potential.
So you will never escape it.
You were really just put
atoms on top of each other.
And trust me, if you work
with Born-Mayer potentials,
and you're not careful,
you will see that.
You will see atoms sitting
on top of each other,
exactly because of this problem.
OK.
I got some Morse potential
parameters out of a book.
It's probably rather useless.
Nobody would use this
anymore for metals
to be honest, because I'll
show you a bit later why.
These pair potentials are
not very good for metals.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: You're asking
about how to calculate.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Let me come to that.
That's a question I will
specifically address, but thank
you.
I wanted to show
you the difference
between a few potentials
for a specific bond.
This is the CH bond in
methane, and so they're all
fitted to have the same bonding
energy and the same modulus.
So the same bond distance,
the same bonding energy,
and same modulus, and
this is the exact curve
in the solid line.
The dash dash dotted
is the Morse potential.
That's actually the one that's
very close to the exact line.
Let's see if I get this right.
This is just a
harmonic potential.
So this is something
like what they call P2.
This is sort of K times
delta R-squared, where
delta R is the distance
away from the equilibrium
bound in geometry, and P4
is a 4th order polynomial.
So that would be K
plus let's say L delta
R cubed to the 4th power.
And I think the
interesting thing
is that near the minimum
they all look the same.
They pretty much have to.
They have the same
position in the minimum,
and they have the
same curvature.
OK?
So if you're only
going to be looking
at very short displacements
around the equilibrium,
actually just your
quadratic is fine,
and you'll see that often.
People who model
small deformations
in organic systems
in polymers and so
will often just use
spring models, essentially
a harmonic potential.
So to decide what
potential you need,
you should think
about how far you want
to go away from equilibrium.
If you go very far away
from equilibrium, obviously,
this Morse potential
does a fine job.
If you stay very
close to equilibrium,
you may not want to
put in that effort.
It's much easier to
work with a spring model
than to actually work
with a Morse potential.
It's much faster to
evaluate a quadratic.
I always thought I should
put a section in my lectures
on how to fit potentials, and
every time, I look up papers,
and I can never find
anything systematic.
So I think the rule
is you fit to anything
you can get your hands on.
And as we'll point out
later more carefully,
since potentials only
have a limited region
of applicability,
you want to fit
as close as possible
to the things
you're going to calculate,
to the environment
but so in theory, that
could be anything.
There's the obvious candidates.
You always want to get the
length scale and the energy
scale pretty much right and
the stiffness, here sort
of obvious.
In some cases, you want to get
low symmetry environment right.
So if you only fit to
crystal structures,
you may have very poor
reproduction of low symmetry
things, like surface energies
or what goes on in a liquid.
And so in some cases, people
explicitly fit to that.
I wouldn't worry
too much about this.
This is going to
become a lot clearer,
as I talk to you about
the physics that's
missing in pair potentials
and how you correct to that.
OK.
So I tried to find
what I thought
is maybe the first example
of computational modeling
with potentials.
It's probably not the first, but
I think maybe one of the first
that was done on computer.
This was done by
Vineyard's group,
and it's essentially studying
radiation damage in copper.
This is from 1960.
I don't know if you remember
punch cards for computers.
I think this is from
before punch cards.
But they managed to program
a small molecular dynamics,
and essentially
what they're doing
is they have a crystal of
copper, and they're shooting--
I think they're
shooting some ions in it
to actually see the orbit that
the radiation damage falls.
So you knock out atoms, and
you show the displacement.
Ironically, this is a simulation
people still do these days.
Molecular dynamics on
radiation damage, so 1960.
OK.
So let me talk a little
about the obvious problems
with pair potentials, and
this is one of the things
that we're going to then
show you in the lab.
We are actually going
to make you demonstrate
this in the lab, and
once you understand
the physical limitations
of pair potential,
you'll see that the solutions
which is pair functional
methods or cluster
potential are actually quite
obvious why they came about.
And when I talk about
failures of pair potentials,
I don't talk about
failures of the parameters.
I talk about
failures of the form,
and there's a lot of
people who say, well,
if this doesn't work, I just
need to change my parameters
in my potential.
There are certain things
that you can never
get right with pair
potentials, because they
are in violation of the
particular form which
is a pairwise interaction.
So one is, obviously, that
pair potentials count bonds.
That's what you
should keep in mind.
They really essentially sum--
the cohesive energy
on an atom is largely
determined by how many things
are around it, because it
literally sums bonds around it.
It doesn't care much about
the organization of atoms.
So if you take this
triangle, let's say
these bonds are
one Angstrom, or I
take this chain, where the
bonds are one Angstrom.
OK?
Here, I have four atoms,
here I have three,
but there are three
bonds in each case.
These have essentially
the same energy
in a pair potential model.
OK?
The only thing that
would distinguish them
is longer range
interactions, but that's not
the physics that in many
cases makes this different.
OK?
The physics that in many
cases makes this different,
for example, could
be angular or bonding
or could be that
the presence of this
truly influences the
bond between these two.
And we'll actually show you
how to solve both problems.
They're actually
different problems that
lead to different solutions.
Another nice example, if you
take a ethylene molecule,
let's say you were
trying to model
that with pair potentials.
If I flap these bonds here,
so I bend open the hydrogens,
that really doesn't
cost me any energy,
if I have a pair potential.
OK?
Because the pair potential
just measures this distance
and this distance.
So if I just flap this open,
that distance stays the same.
OK?
Only if you had some
indirect interaction
between these
hydrogens would you
pick up that energy difference.
But you see, if you
made a potential
between the hydrogens, you'd be
putting the wrong physics in.
Because the reason that energy
changes, as I change that band,
has nothing to do
with the interaction
between the hydrogens.
But it has all to do with the
hybridization of the carbon,
that the carbon is sp2
hybridized and one certain bond
angles.
OK?
So it's not because you can
fix it with pair potentials
that you fix it right.
OK.
The other thing you will see
is, if you use pair potentials,
and you look say for low
energy crystal structures,
you will almost always end
up in close-packed systems.
And the reason is that
in pair potential models,
atoms try to maximize their
coordination, because really
you sum the energy pairwise
coming from atoms around you.
So if you have a
negative bonding energy
with atoms around
you, you try to get
as many as you can
around you, so you
will maximize coordination.
The ground states of most
potential models for elements
are HCP Hexagonal Close-Packed
and FCC Face-Centered
Close-Packed.
OK?
So it's extremely hard
to stabilize things
like a diamond cubic structure
which is an open structure.
I don't know if you
have a picture for it.
The other thing which
is maybe more obvious,
but pair potentials are
not stable against shear,
and now you could argue
most materials aren't
stable against shear.
But if I take the
square of atoms--
let's say this is just
a piece of a lattice.
OK-- if I shear this, I
can shear this and keep
all these distances the same.
So in a nearest
neighbor pair potential,
all the energy has not changed.
So if the energy
has not changed,
that means that my elastic
constant in shear is 0.
OK?
Now, you could say, this is why
real materials on form square
lattices and simple
cubic lattice, and that's
actually true.
But a real material has
some amount of resistance
against shear, even in
a square configuration.
And here you see
by construction,
it doesn't have any resistance.
OK.
What I'm going to do is
try to break down what
in different materials classes,
like metals or organic solids,
what the failures
of pair potentials,
and then we'll go into what
the remedies are for that.
So in metals, the main
thing is this problem.
That if you do a
pair potential model,
and you look at the bonding
energy of this red atom,
it's really
essentially six times
the single bond energy of
the red with the white one.
And so that's why
for pair potentials,
people say that cohesive
energy scales with Z which
is the coordination number.
And if you do quantum mechanics
or even more approximate theory
but that have the essentials
of hybridization in them,
you find that actually for
metals-- and with metals,
I mean things that have
covalent delocalized bonding,
which you call
metallic bonding--
the cohesive energy of an atom
goes like the square root of Z.
OK?
So it's not linear in Z at all.
So if you have more
bonds, you start
gaining less and
less incrementally,
and you can see that.
I made a picture here.
This is out of a, I think,
what's really a great article,
if you want to read
more about this.
It's a review article on
the embedded atom method.
We'll put this on the restricted
side of the course website.
This is actually for
nickel, the cohesive energy
per atom as a function of
the coordination it's in.
So of course, 12 here,
this is the FCC solid.
2 is the dimer.
So this is just two
atoms in the gas phase,
and what do you think is 11?
How do you get 11?
This is actually
experimental data.
11 is from the vacancy
formation energy.
If you make a vacancy in a
crystal, the atoms around it
are 11-fold coordinated
instead of 12.
In FCC, you have
12-fold coordination,
but if you take an atom away,
those atoms around there
have 11-fold coordination.
So this comes from the
vacancy coordination.
Now, there's three points here.
They drew a square
root through them.
You probably could
draw other things,
but what we do know
from quantum mechanics
is that essentially the first
order is square root of Z
behavior and now Z behavior.
You can also see
that in silicon.
This is a slightly
confusing graph,
but this is the energy per
bond in red for silicon
in different coordinations.
OK?
So what you see is that
the energy per bond
actually goes down as
you make more bonds.
So even though as you
coordinate an atom
with more atoms around it,
the total cohesive energy
may go down.
If you divide that energy
by the number of bonds,
that number becomes
smaller and smaller.
OK?
It's almost like an atom
in a covalent bonding
has only so much
bonding power to give,
and if it only
bonds to one atom,
it gives all its bonding
power to that one atom.
If it has to bond
to a lot, it has
to divide that
between all those.
So this is an important
concept to remember,
that in covalent
materials, cohesive energy
is not linear in coordination.
Bonding strength gets weaker,
as you add more bonds,
and we'll come back to that.
This is important
when you go between--
when you make potentials in
one coordination environment
and start using
them in another one.
Here's a quantum mechanical
result for aluminum.
So this is the
cohesive energy, again,
as a function of the
coordination number.
So this is actually
a calculation,
and again what you see is that,
even though as you coordinate
more the cohesive
energy goes down,
but it doesn't go down linear.
If you want to think
of it, the increment
you're getting
from adding a bond
starts getting
smaller and smaller.
If you go from one
to two, you could say
this is your bonding energy.
This is the extra
energy you get.
If you go from 11 to 12,
all you gain is this.
So the bond energy, when
you go from the 11 to 12
is much smaller than the bonding
energy when you go from 1 to 2.
OK?
So the cohesive energy
with coordination
is a convex function.
That's important
to keep in mind.
And of course, you cannot get
that with pair potentials.
With pair potentials, this
will essentially look linear.
Now, what's the slope of
it in pair potentials?
It's a trick question.
What's the slope of that line?
Well, Z's the coordinate, so
I need the factor in front.
See, the problem
is you don't know.
This is in the end the
fundamental problem.
It depends on where you fit it.
If you fit from 11 to 12--
if you fit from 11 to 12,
then this is your slope.
Then, you're going
to have this curve.
If you fit from 1 to 2, you're
going to have this curve.
And do you see that they
really give substantial error
when you go away from the
coordination in which you fit?
I'm going to show you
that with the last result.
This is basically
saying the same thing.
What I took here, this is out
of Anders Karlsson's paper
which is on our reference list,
which we've put on the web.
This is a great review
paper on potentials,
and not just pair potentials.
And we give with every main
topic-- not every lecture--
with every main topic, we
have a list of references,
and they just go on the
Additional Materials
on the Stellar website.
This is the pair
potential for copper
fitted to different properties.
The lowest one is the one fitted
to the dimer, to the molecule.
So this is just a
copper-copper dimer.
You see, it's the
strongest of them all.
It's the strongest of all
the potentials, and why,
because there's only one bond.
OK?
You remember, all the bonding
energy goes in that one bond.
The equation of state,
that's essentially
looking at the cohesive energy
of the solid as a function
of lattice parameter.
So this one, that's
almost the smallest one.
That's the solid.
See, a lot smaller,
because you're counting now
bond strength in coordination
12, where every bond is weaker.
So you try to map that
onto a pair potential,
and you get, in some sense,
a much weaker interaction
per pair.
And what Anders Karlsson did, he
also extracted it from phonons.
This is actually one.
It's really small
and from defects,
and the defect one even
has a different minimum.
Actually, they all have
a different minimum.
So what this is telling you,
what I'm trying to demonstrate,
is that for metals and for
anything that's actually
covalent, but this is worse
for covalent delocalized,
your potential is extremely
environment-dependent.
It's essentially
coordination-dependent.
OK?
And we show you in
the next lecture
how that shows up in
certain physical properties
and then how you solve that.
Because turns out, there's
a very elegant solution
to the problem, and I
think you can already see
where we're going to take this.
The problem is that
our bonding energy
is linear in coordination
with a pair potential.
So all we need to do
to fix this problem is
to make it nonlinear,
and that leads you
into what are called pair
functionals, rather than pair
potentials.
And things like there's a
whole class of methods, things
like the embedded atom
method, glue models,
effective medium theory, they
all go be different names,
are essentially pair
functional models.
There are still
things that count
the coordination around you
in some form or another.
It's just that they make
the energy evolve nonlinear
with that coordination, and
they're very elegant methods.
They're still empirical
methods, but very
elegant methods that solve
the essential problem of pair
potentials without
a lot of extra work,
and so we'll talk
about that on Thursday.
So I'll end here.
I'll be happy, if
there are questions,
I'd be happy to take questions.
Professor Marzari and I
will be here for a few
more minutes, if there's anybody
that has questions about how
the course will run in general.